[Music]
surfing in Portugal it's more than a
sport it's a way of life the Atlantic's
waves draw Surfers from across the globe
to kakavelos beach near Lisbon
[Music]
and 14 year old Maria Sosa is here too
for her it's second nature to jump into
the waves despite her [ __ ] paraplegia
we're surfers
it's pretty hard if you haven't done it
before
but it's no problem if you've been at it
for years
has Down syndrome and brain damage
because he didn't get enough oxygen at
Birth
but he's 47 now and Unstoppable
Kaya and Maria are involved in Surf
addict an association for adapted
surfing
I've been a regular ever since I first
met the group
before they head out into the water the
Surfers and helpers warm up
today's knows what it comes down to
Happy have fun about being there and
doing something for your body and mind
everybody love surfing everybody loves
to be at the beach everybody loves to
socialize this is a therapy not only for
the Surfers but also for the volunteers
and their families
[Music]
and then it's time Kaya and his friends
want to finally ride some waves
[Music]
they're in their element out here on the
surfboard they get a better feeling for
what they're truly capable of
[Music]
you're in the water and you just scream
you're so happy and you're afraid to do
so because you're out in the sea
is
[Music]
and the trainer Theresa also keeps
experiencing new things with the group
I've learned a lot with disabled people
they made me sometimes think about my
everyday life if I complain with because
of such a small thing why why should I
complain
I should be grateful to be able to do
things on my own and to go surfing
also entails a great deal of
responsibility and things don't always
go smoothly
Alfonso just got washed off his board
everyone pitches in including Kaya he
wants to be a role model for people with
disabilities
um
I want to help others learn to surf even
despite their disabilities
the producers
two hours later Maria is exhausted but
she's already looking forward to her
next training session on kakavela speech
ERS
the main thing is I want to keep going
[Music]
foreign
and the others say basically anyone can
surf
and in Portugal surfing is a way of life
[Music]